now do you remember the lion's share of
our thought here was really invested
here how many terms on it okay that's
not a bad thing to do you really need to
think carefully about how teachers there
are at any sequence or series that is a
very very work i think to understand
however do not need to know how many
terms there are in this series to solve
this question ok now for two reasons
right firstly we know the last term is
I'm going to show you a technique that
does that in fact maybe I'll maybe I'll
show you that first because it is the
last I'll make the last saving for fast
this one ok so here we go what we're
going to do is I'm going to try and take
advantage of the fact that I know what
the last term is I want to point out to
you though um the formula that we
learned from when you know the first
term and you know the last term what
kind of series does it apply to it
applies to AP's right what was our
formula I'll give you a clue it started
with Iran to what happened after that
just a puzzle right first term last time
there's the pair anything that happens
this is the story with gas trimmer ok
now unfortunately you can't simply well
yeah unfortunately and obviously you
can't do that here because this is a GP
and pair terms do not care up as simply
as they do in an AP right so I can't
just use this but I can still take
advantage of knowing what the last term
is here's the way I'm going to do it I'm
going to so maybe you want to put like a
little subheading right using the last
term
so method 1 was using the formula method
2 is using the last term ok now the way
i'm going to show you there is a way to
like is an equivalent to this up for gps
which I've deliberately not showing you
because it doesn't come up that often
but it does come up and also the reason
why I didn't show you is because you can
get it out from the formula which you
already know ok so I want you to recall
this ok so this is our our launching
point last time right I want to take
this and I want you to notice if you can
look hard enough the last term inverted
commas last term the last term of the GP
is hiding in the formula it's not
obvious but it's hiding there in fact
you should remember when we developed
this formula the first time right we
ended up getting a first term and a last
term and all those intervening terms in
the middle they did cancel out so the
question is where is the last turn where
is he hiding in there let me help you
see him again ok let's expand the
numerator I get this do you agree that
that's just I just extended the brackets
right the last time is almost there the
nth term of this series right where is
where is he what is the end service year
it's a r and n minus one right there n
minus 1 times what I almost have it
there on the numerator do you see it
there how do i turn this guy into AR to
the n minus 1 and the answer is this is
how many lots of the retcon ratio answer
mm lots of them right if I want to have
n minus 1 mods I just have to take one
of the eyes out right do you agree with
that if I want to turn and into this
like if this is out of the five and what
I really wanted is out of the four they
will take the fifth our app just just
pull them out the front and what you'll
be left with is a R to the N minus 1
that's the end of term in there except
the nth term is really what we mean by
the last term right that's L
they're so in fact what we're about to
right now he are a minus r l if you want
you can put kind of a boxer on this
because this is the GP equivalent on
this guy right if you know what the last
time is and the ratio and the first turn
off you go you can work out the whole
Sun right let's quickly give it a go I
already worked out what a and R ah so
I've got the first turn I've got the
common ratio what is the last selling it
three the three in all / now this guy is
going to be still one takeaway negative
3 but just like it was before now what
if I got 3 to the N double negative so
dominated it there's a 3 there and
there's a three to the 3n what happens
to the embassies this is a one right 3n
plus one sabbath we are ya all divided
by four was that easier or was it hard I
think it was easier because I didn't
even know how many terms there were okay
admittedly as you see this work here and
I don't really I don't think you know in
a min amidst the hundreds of things you
need to memorize I don't think this is
particularly worth memorizing it's a
little bit like this guy okay I mean if
you want to memorize it you know go for
your life but in a crowded brain in a
crowd of rain I would much prefer that
you just memorize this right remember is
this guy and then you divide by whatever
you want to get all the other versions
of the Pythagorean identity okay
including 1 plus 10 squared equals sex
squared by dividing everything through
by cos cos squared right so I i would
not memorize this guy personally i
wouldn't i wouldn't invest time
memorizing you you don't see him nearly
enough to warrant yes i'll commit this
to memory and is reverberating for me um
this kind of question here were
happening student
useful doesn't come up frequently okay
so yeah so yeah they will give you the
last term in exactly this kind of
situation right where you can't actually
named what the last term is it's on
indeterminate length and the only way
you can know when it ends you can't say
all this has you know five terms or 15
terms the whole point is I don't know
how many terms there are and that's what
makes the question challenging okay so
it's in this particular situation that
this is particularly you search as well
I don't want memory